this revision shows four key moments of  the European integration process the  beginning signing of the treaty  enrollment 57 the economy our Europe out  its citizen to become more prosperous  social how to share this richness and  then our role in the world our Europe  can play a significant support for a  better world in terms of the environment  peace freedom democracy for the older  generation it represents the fact that  European nations top to have war among  them for younger people exceeds the  possibility to study in another country  to add more possibility on the labour  market of course for many European  citizen this is also a moment of the  satisfaction of disappointment it's very  difficulty to build something like the  European Union it's very easy to destroy  but once you've destroyed it the future  can be very good for everybody my  parents were the generation is so ash  with my sons are Erasmus generation I'm  in the middle and I'm a little proud of  it